on sait pas très bien ce qu'il a voulu
faire
il est revenu dans le salon
il perdait tellement fort que là il fait
c'est à cet endroit que Hugues va perdre
connaissance puis mourir
seulement il reste deux énigmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur mer en Bretagne
nous sommes dans la nuit du 3 au 4 juin
2016 François de la Plaza et son épouse
Mireille son réveillé brutalement par la
sonnerie du téléphone c'est le lundi
matin à 4h30
le téléphone sonne
à l'autre bout du fil mélissan x c'est
l'ex petit ami de leur fils Hugues de la
Plaza elle appelle depuis les États-Unis
[Musique]
j'ai de mauvaises nouvelles et je l'ai
dit en français j'ai dit
trois mots qui laissent François sans
voix
son fils unique vient de mourir à
l'autre bout du monde
il est mort
alors là la catastrophe c'est le rideau
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
sous le coup de l'émotion et dans un
français approximatif Mélissa a du mal à
expliquer les circonstances troubles
dans lesquelles le jeune Français est
mort
[Musique]
apparemment il avait été il avait été
tué
[Musique]
à Hugues de la Plaza et pourquoi sa mort
mystérieuse pose tant de questions
voici l'histoire d'une invraisemblable
enquête et du combat d'un père pour
connaître la vérité sur la mort de son
enfant
sur le couteau il y a des tâches de sang
donc c'est l'arme du crime
[Musique]
de drogue dans ce quartier
San Francisco États-Unis nous sommes le
3 juin 2016
dans cet immeuble du centre-ville l'un
des habitants de la résidence sort sur
le perron
il fait aussitôt une étrange découverte
un voisin de palier sort de chez lui
pour aller travailler il remarque
d'importantes tâches de sang
[Musique]
partout sur le Peron
aussitôt l'homme appelle le SF [__] la
police de San Francisco une fois sur
place les enquêteurs cherchent à savoir
ce qu'il s'est passé
un petit peu comme le Petit Poucet ils
suivent les traces de sang pour arriver
jusqu'à la porte du domicile de
l'appartement duc de la Plaza
mais la porte de l'appartement est
fermée à clé alors les policiers passent
par derrière
[Musique]
et une fois à l'intérieur il découvre un
véritable carnage
[Musique]
il y a du sang au sol quelques objets
sont renversés dans le fond de
l'appartement il trouve le corps de
Hugues de la Plaza
un jeune français de 37 ans
il a trois blessures au total sur le
côté gauche
assez bas au niveau du ventre un peu
plus haut dans l'abdomen et au niveau de
la gorge où il est très sérieusement
touché
que lui est-il arrivé exactement
trop tôt pour le dire une chose est sûre
il ne s'agit pas d'un crime de rôdeur
un téléphone
et puis il y a le portefeuille du jeune
homme qui est retrouvé avec une liasse
de billets de banque
l'appartement est verrouillé de
l'intérieur et toutes les fenêtres sont
fermées
aucune trace d'effraction ni de vol un
corps lardé de coups de couteau la mort
de Hugues de la Plaza et pour l'instant
un mystère
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique en
Bretagne
l'incompréhension est totale
Mireille et François de la Plaza les
parents de Hugues décrivent leur fils
comme un garçon sans histoire
[Musique]
très discret jamais se mettant en avant
c'est pour ça qu'il avait voulu beaucoup
de camarades parce qu'il avait ce
contact
facilement
il était très drôle
ingénieur du son de formation Hugues
décide à 28 ans de partir aux États-Unis
pour vivre le rêve américain
il a eu l'idée de partir directement à
New York comme ça ils sont équipés dans
la poche voilà c'est comme ça
[Musique]
et c'est à New York que Hugues va
rencontrer Mélissa
immédiatement c'est le coup de foudre
à l'exposition
je me souviens de voir ce si bel homme
dans un bon costume
comme ça a été sympa discret elle est le
flash tout de suite et lui aussi ça a
marché tout de suite très bien
et je lui ai proposé qu'on se revoit
nous sommes sortis
le jeune couple est si amoureux que
lorsque Mélissa doit quitter New York
pour San Francisco Hugues n'hésite pas à
la suivre
il a atterri à San Francisco et 15 jours
après trois semaines il a retrouvé le
travail c'était comment
le jeune homme partage sa vie entre la
France et les États-Unis
il semble heureux
même si sa relation avec Mélissa et
parfois tourmenté
[Musique]
mais nous étions vraiment amoureux et
puis finalement bah le couple va se
séparer mais il reste en excellent
termes
[Musique]
pour les proches du jeune homme sa mort
est inexplicable
tout s'attendent beaucoup de l'enquête
de la police américaine et ils ne vont
pas tarder à avoir des premières
réponses
[Musique]
à San Francisco l'enquête avant sa grand
pas
en effet la scène de crime va parler
d'abord des éléments déterminants laisse
penser que Hugues de la Plaza était seul
au moment des faits
parce que les gouttes de sang qu'on
retrouve au sol semble être tombé à la
plomb a priori pas de lutte donc il y a
bien des traces de pas
mais ce ne sont pas celles du ou des
meurtriers
les traces de pas qu'on a retrouvées
dans le sang
il y a quelqu'un qui a marché dans les
flaques de sang on s'aperçoit que c'est
les pas de Hugues de la Plaza donc là
encore pas d'intervention de d'un tiers
extérieur
dans la cuisine les policiers américains
vont même retrouver ce qu'ils pensent
être l'arme du crime
il retrouve plusieurs couteaux dans
l'évier dont un qui a été nettoyé et qui
va être dans l'esprit des policiers
probablement l'arme du crime
avec une lame comme ça
la lame du couteau aurait donc
bizarrement été nettoyé mais les
policiers remarquent tout de même
quelques légères traces rouges sur le
manche
s'agit-il de traces de sang le couteau
est mis sous scellé
[Musique]
après plusieurs heures passées dans
l'appartement les enquêteurs semblent
déjà avoir leur petite idée du scénario
qui a pu se dérouler la veille au soir
et leur intuition va être confirmé en
interrogeant les voisins
[Musique]
dans l'immeuble où vit Hugues de la
Plaza les trois autres appartements sont
occupés
les voisins sont donc interrogés un nain
en fait personne n'a rien entendu sauf
une voisine
gitan jalibuscian vit dans l'appartement
situé juste à côté de celui de Hugues de
la Plaza
elle raconte qu'elle est son mari ont
été réveillés au beau milieu de la nuit
on a entendu une petite souris
[Musique]
en même temps c'est étrange c'est
bizarre et là les bruits se sont arrêtés
le couple affirme alors s'être rendormie
car les bruits avaient cessé
des portes qui claquent au beau milieu
de la nuit mais sans un cri les
enquêteurs ne voient qu'une explication
possible au décès duc de la Plaza une
conclusion pour le moins surprenante
qu'il va maintenant falloir annoncer à
la famille du jeune homme et à ses
proches
[Musique]
cinq jours après la mort de leur enfant
François et Mireille de la Plaza arrive
à San Francisco
il ne parle pas un mot d'anglais alors
Mélissa et un ami de leur fils les
accompagne à la police
[Musique]
nous avons rencontré les policiers et
évidemment il ne s'attendait pas à
entendre ce qu'ils vont entendre
la police on a été extrêmement déçu
[Musique]
la réaction des parents
c'est incompréhensible
il se trouve quelque part de voir ce qui
se passe en plus de la manière dont il a
été tué trois coups de couteau bon le
suicide
c'est là où on a compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui allait pas
que Hugues c'était suscité
les proches du jeune Français tombent
des nues comment leur fils et amis
a-t-il pu se suicider de trois coups de
couteau
mais les policiers avancent des
arguments
d'abord ils affirment que Hugues étaient
seuls chez lui
parce que la porte est verrouillée de
l'intérieur
et la porte sur le jardin était
verrouillée
selon la police américaine Hugues de la
Plaza était donc seul chez lui et il se
serait donné la mort à l'aide d'un
couteau celui souvenez-vous qui a été
saisi dans l'évier de la cuisine
[Musique]
et puis preuve ultime pour les
enquêteurs quelques lignes griffonnées
par la victime sur un carnet retrouvé à
son domicile
il s'agit en fait d'une citation de
Gandhi
[Musique]
meurtre sous le tapis
de terminer le reste
aux Etats-Unis l'affaire Hugues de la
Plaza est classé avec les affaires
nonélucidées
[Musique]
François le père de la victime et
furieux il décide alors de mener sa
propre enquête pour connaître enfin la
vérité sur la mort de son fils
[Musique]
en interrogeant les amis de son fils
François va très vite trouver des
éléments qui ne collent pas avec la
thèse du suicide
d'abord Hugues étaient loin d'être en
dépression
[Musique]
qui était déprimé le lendemain il avait
deux rendez-vous sur une vie en moto
rendez-vous avec un copain un copain
français qui travaille à Los Angeles qui
est en relation avec lui la taille de
Fifi des
fourmille de projets et n'avaient aucun
problème d'argent bien au contraire
[Musique]
il avait envie de changer d'air il avait
une envisagé de partir en Argentine il
avait été en Argentine la buenover il
avait regardé ce qu'il pouvait faire
là-bas il était plus ou moins prêt à
partir il avait pas le choix
vous croyez que c'est un métier
[Musique]
les proches de la victime se demandent
alors si les policiers américains ont
sérieusement fait leur travail car on se
plongeant dans le dossier de Topsy
François de la Plaza va découvrir que
plusieurs
erreurs grossières ont été commises
dans le rapport du médecin légiste elle
stipule que Hugues de la Plaza est
circoncis or Hugues de la Plaza n'était
pas circoncis et ce n'est pas la seule
erreur
ils disent que
74 la musique
et le père de la victime n'est pas au
bout de ses surprises
souvenez-vous le matin du crime une mare
de sang est découverte sur le perron de
l'immeuble
or ces traces de sang capitale pour
l'enquête vont être effacées à 10h ou
11h les pompiers ont passé au karcher
tout le sang qui avait sur les le perron
même que les analyses en Dieu pourquoi
faire une chose pareille
mais il y a plus incroyable encore le
couteau aztèque dans l'évier de la
cuisine serait selon la police l'arme
avec laquelle Hulk se serait lui-même
poignardé
alors comment expliquer que la lame de
ce couteau était retrouvée propre
comme si elle avait été nettoyée
la police s'attache à dire que il se
suicide et ensuite dans un souci de
propreté alors qu'il y a du sang partout
dans l'appartement il va nettoyer son
couteau avant d'aller mourir là on est
au confins de la folie
le remettre dans l'évier américain
rien à faire comme ça pourquoi la police
de San Francisco réfute-t-elle la thèse
du meurtre est-ce par mauvaise foi ou
par manque de moyens François de la
Plaza ne va pas tarder à trouver des
réponses à ces questions
face au manquement de la police et pour
découvrir la vérité sur la mort de son
fils François de la Plaza décide alors
de faire appel à un professionnel
[Musique]
ce détective privé le voici
et si il est connu dans la baie de San
Francisco c'est que depuis 25 ans il dit
avoir enquêté avec son cabinet sur plus
de 5000 à faire
[Musique]
lorsque François de la Plaza la pelle le
détective n'hésite pas un instant
[Musique]
c'était une affaire intéressante et
internationale dès le début il y avait
des problèmes il n'y avait pas d'armes
et des policiers
ça n'avait aucun sens et c'était très
intéressant pour moi
pour John Murphy ce genre d'affaires
classées est assez fréquent aux
États-Unis et pour cause
vous savez si on classe l'affaire si
elle est retirée de la liste des
homicides et replacer sur la liste des
affaires non élucidées et bien au lieu
d'avoir 80 monstres cette année on en a
que 70 juifs
[Musique]
je pense que la police a classé la mort
en suicide car il comptait sur plusieurs
éléments
vous n'avez pas de famille aux
États-Unis il était de nationalité
française
mais il y a une autre raison pour
peut-être expliquer pourquoi la police
américaine a classé en suicide ce qui
ressemble en tout point à un meurtre
pour le maire de la mer qui à l'époque
était
il était en train de préparer son
élection en tant que gouverneur de
Californie
le détective John Murphy se met au
travail
il reprend l'enquête depuis le départ
et ce qu'il va découvrir va conforter la
piste du meurtre
[Musique]
en interrogeant les proches de Hugues
John Murphy le détective découvre que la
victime avait quelques peu changé depuis
sa séparation avec Mélissa le jeune
homme semblait être devenu addict au
sexe
autant que possible
et ce n'est pas tout le détective
découvre que ces derniers temps il
arrivait à Hugues de bois et parfois
même de se droguer chose que ses parents
ignoraient
un peu trop là j'étais très surpris il
découvre que son fils de temps en temps
sa alcoolisait lourdement il découvre
également qu'il lui arrivait aussi de
prendre quelques rails de cocaïne pour
prolonger ses fêtes
c'est les soirées là-bas
mais ça on était absolument pas au
courant
faites drogue alcool conquête amoureuse
autant de pistes possibles que la police
ne semble pas avoir prise en compte et
que John ne détective va s'attacher à
explorer une à une
[Musique]
10 jours après la mort du jeune Français
le détective décide de se rendre sur les
lieux du crime
et pour lui les traces de sang sur le
perron permettent d'échafauder un
premier scénario
Hugues rentrez chez lui quand il a été
sauvagement agressé
moi je crois qu'il a été poignardé à
l'extérieur justice
quelque part entre ici et là
il y avait une grosse tache de sang
et ensuite
elles existent ces traces de sang et il
faut les prendre en considération pour
essayer de comprendre comment les choses
se sont passées
selon John Murphy le soir de sa mort
Hugues de la Plaza est rentré à pied
d'une soirée passée dans un bar situé à
une dizaine de minutes de chez lui
[Musique]
selon lui il est tout à fait possible
qu'en chemin le jeune homme est fait une
mauvaise rencontre
entre le bas
si vous voulez vous faire tuer ou faire
baisser acheter ou vendre de la drogue
c'est laquelle
[Musique]
de la vie pour rentrer chez lui ce n'est
pas un endroit très sûr
donc il a peut-être essayé de trouver de
la drogue bien qu'ils droguait pas
vraiment
pour le détective une chose est sûre
Hugues a été agressé devant son domicile
c'est aussi la conviction du père de la
victime et voici selon lui comment les
choses se seraient passées
il frappait à l'extérieur
il ouvre la porte il rentre
une trace de doigt en haut de la porte
il pousse la porte comme ça elle se
ferme automatiquement et il ferme le
verrou
est allé dans la cuisine
on sait pas très bien ce qu'il a voulu
faire
qui est revenu dans le salon
il perdait tellement fort que là
c'est à cet endroit que Hugues va perdre
connaissance puis mourir
seulement il reste deux énigmes
si Hugues est victime d'une agression
devant chez lui pourquoi va-t-il dans la
cuisine au fond de l'appartement au lieu
d'appeler les secours américain est
composé le fameux 911
[Musique]
il aurait aussitôt appelé les secours
pour le détective ici Hugues n'a pas
appelé les secours cela tient uniquement
à la gravité de ses blessures
la quantité de sang qui l'a perdu dans
la chute qui a suivi l'agression la
rendue incapable de penser est-ce que je
dois appeler
je pense que 3 minutes c'est le maximum
de temps pour réagir surtout avec sa
blessure à la gorge
et puis il reste à élucider un autre
mystère
[Musique]
si Hugues a été agressé devant chez lui
alors pourquoi les voisins n'ont rien
entendu
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas de bruit d'agression ou
quoi que ce soit cela
ont entendu un peu d'agitation
étrange en effet
[Musique]
grâce aux éléments d'enquêtes recueillis
par le détective
puisque la police américaine a
définitivement opté pour la thèse du
suicide
[Musique]
François de la Plaza le père de la
victime a une idée
il décide de mettre son affaire sur la
place publique et pour cela il a une
alliée de poids
Mélissa
l'ex-petitami de son fils
journaliste de formation
[Musique]
est une journaliste
on a commencé à parler à différents
journaux télévisions radio
François était souvent à la tête d'une
manifestation ou en train de faire une
déclaration devant la mairie pour
réclamer justice
on a commencé à avoir des journalistes
qui ont un cri des papiers
accablants donc l'affaire est devenue
publique
malgré le battage médiatique la police
américaine ne réagit toujours pas
l'enquête reste au point mort
[Musique]
six mois après la mort de Hugues de la
Plaza François son père doit se rendre à
l'évidence la police américaine ne
l'aidera pas
l'homme rentre en France et c'est là que
l'enquête va connaître un incroyable
rebondissement
car le Breton n'a pas dit son dernier
mot
pour aller voir le porter plainte auprès
du tribunal à Paris
trouver un avocat boom boom des
démarches quoi
et fait rarissime une commission
rogatoire internationale est ordonnée
l'enquête est relancée
une juge d'instruction et deux officiers
de police judiciaire sont donc envoyés à
San Francisco
[Musique]
une victoire pour les proches de Hugues
de la Plaza
[Musique]
après la mort
on était tous très content que les
policiers français arrivent parce que la
police américaine n'avait pas pris la
faire au sérieux
des caméras des journalistes il y avait
des conférences de presse
c'est la première fois dans les annales
de la ville que ça a été ça a été fait
donc c'était c'est une occasion
extrêmement rare
habituelle pour les États-Unis
gouvernement étranger et besoins de
venir pour faire une investigation digne
de ce nom tellement la police une
capacité donc ce serait d'ailleurs bien
passé Antonio gasillas l'inspecteur
américain qui était en charge de
l'affaire
[Musique]
des policiers français qui viennent d'un
petit pays qui viennent ici
patauger dans son enquête ce n'est pas
lui faire plaisir
la police américaine voit d'un tel
mauvaise oeil il arrivait de leur
collègue français qu'elle ne va pas leur
faciliter le travail
[Musique]
Washington pour qu'il leur dise
à transmettre les éléments du dossier
français
une fois le dossier en main les
policiers français vont enfin pouvoir
commencer à travailler lorsque les
policiers français commencent leurs
investigations il s'aperçoit de
l'étendue des dégâts du travail des
policiers américains
les enquêteurs français se demandent
alors pourquoi autant de questions sont
restées sans réponse
comment expliquer cet âge de sang dans
l'appartement mais aussi sur le perron
pourquoi les portes étaient-elles
verrouillées de l'intérieur
pourquoi les voisins n'ont rien entendu
quel est l'arme du crime et surtout qui
pouvait en vouloir à ce jeune français
de 37 ans
[Musique]
les policiers français décident de
reprendre toute l'enquête à zéro d'abord
ils établissent une liste de suspects
très larges ce que leur confrères
américains ne semblaient pas s'être
donné la peine de faire tous les proches
de la victime commencent par être
suspectés
ses collègues de travail
les parents ils ont commencé une vraie
enquête
convoquait chacun et ont interrogé plus
de 70 personnes
moi j'ai été réinterviewé et j'ai été
interviewé en tant que suspect
comme il se doit puisque j'étais un ami
proche tous les proches doivent être des
suspects
en 15 jours ils ont bien vu que les
sporiciens Américains n'avaient rien
fait du tout ils ont analysé tous les
coups de téléphone analyser son
ordinateur
emmener des échantillons qui ont été
analysés au laboratoire de la police
scientifique à Paris
et les premiers résultats d'analyse des
laboratoires français ne vont pas tarder
à conforter la thèse du meurtre
contrairement à ce qu'affirmer la police
américaine Hugues n'avait pas pris de
drogue le soir de sa mort
la police américaine voulait pousser la
théorie du suicide où l'emprise de
stupéfiant et heureusement il n'avait
pas pris de drogue
plus surprenant encore ces analyses
scientifiques vont également révéler une
chose incroyable
concernant le fameux couteau aztèque
retrouvé chez Hugues dans la cuisine
depuis le début on prend pour argent
comptant que sur le couteau il y a des
tâches de sang donc c'est l'arme du
crime puisqu'il y a du sang sur le
couteau or à l'analyse il a fallu
attendre je ne sais combien de temps
pour ça à l'analyse on s'aperçoit que
c'est du ketchup
la police a pris du simple ketchup pour
du sang
les lacunes de l'enquête américaine
éclatent alors au grand jour
d'autant que la lame de ce couteau ne
correspond pas aux blessures de la
victime
[Musique]
d'après le médecin légiste français
l'arme du crime serait plutôt un couteau
de chasse
[Musique]
la thèse du suicide de Hugues de la
Plaza vient donc d'être officiellement
récusé la police de San Francisco est
montrée du doigt
[Musique]
il fonctionnaires de police américaines
qui avaient été chargés de ce dossier
ont finalement été dessaisies
et envoyé à la douane des aéroports
pour François de la Plaza et les proches
de Hugues c'est une revanche grâce au
travail des enquêteurs français ils vont
être en mesure de savoir avec précision
comment leur fils et amis a vécu ces
dernières heures
[Musique]
ce que la police américaine n'avait pas
fait la police française va le faire à
savoir analyser l'ordinateur analyser le
téléphone et l'exploiter savoir quels
sont les derniers appels et
accessoirement les SMS
grâce aux informations collectées les
enquêteurs savent que le jeune ingénieur
du son passe la journée du vendredi à
son travail
puis qu'il quitte son bureau il est 17
heures
il rentre chez lui après son travail et
cet après-midi
rentre donc chez lui vers 22h mais il
n'y reste pas vu que voulait sortir ce
soir
[Musique]
là c'est d'avoir une conversation avec
lui au bar il avait les dents blanches
et le tarot il est heureux il souriait
elle avait un peu bu
voici la toute dernière photo de Hugues
de la Plaza prise par l'un de ses amis
quelques minutes avant sa mort
il est deux heures du matin
l'établissement ferme tout le monde sort
du bar
les amis de Hugues proposent de
prolonger la soirée ailleurs mais le
jeune homme refuse il a d'autres projets
expliquent-ils
sur Internet
[Musique]
Hugues et bel et bien rentré chez lui
directement après avoir quitté ses amis
l'analyse de son ordinateur va apporter
une précision horaire il est deux heures
18 quand il allume son appareil
il se connecte alors à un site de
rencontre
mais une demi-heure plus tard il se
passe quelque chose d'étrange
les policiers français ont été capables
de déterminer que l'ordinateur a été
coupé
en effet à deux heures 40 précisément le
câble d'alimentation est débranché de
façon inopinée ce qui va engendrer un
message d'erreur
j'ai débranché d'une manière anormale
d'après eux
pourquoi c'est pas
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il ce samedi 3 juin 2007
dont l'appartement de Hugues de la Plaza
à deux heures 40
pourquoi le câble de son ordinateur
a-t-il été comme arraché
une chose est certaine le français était
bel et bien vivant jusqu'à cette
heure-ci
[Musique]
après avoir reconstitué l'emploi du
temps de la victime les policiers
français vont réinterroger les voisins
de Hugues de la Plaza et ils vont faire
une incroyable découverte
le propriétaire du garage bleu situé à
gauche de la résidence du jeune homme a
fait installer il y a quelques années un
dispositif de vidéosurveillance
[Musique]
il y avait plusieurs caméras vidéos de
en particulier
sur un ouest
aussi un vrai semblable que cela puisse
paraître les policiers américains
n'avaient pas exploité l'enregistrement
cependant en visionnant les bandes les
Français vont déchanter
[Musique]
seule la caméra à l'ouest fonctionnait
et on l'a visionnant les enquêteurs
découvrent qu'à deux heures 16 un
individu se dirige vers l'immeuble duc
de la Plaza
[Musique]
il y a une ombre qui passe et on croit
reconnaître Hugues mais on voit rien
d'autre
les enquêteurs s'interrogent alors et si
le tueur avait échappé à l'objectif cela
est possible car cette caméra de vidéo
surveillance est un peu particulière
[Musique]
elle ne filme en réalité qu'une image
toutes les quatre secondes
[Musique]
si quelqu'un en passant très vite
n'aurait pas eu le temps de passer sans
être filmé
cette caméra ne sait-on pas jusqu'au
Péron de l'appartement de Hugues
et se dirigent vers sa porte la caméra
ne couvre pas cette partie
sur les images vidéos les enquêteurs
français pensent donc qu'il s'agit bien
de Hugues de la Plaza
cela prouve que le jeune homme est bien
seul lorsqu’il rentre chez lui à deux
heures 16
alors une nouvelle piste se dessine si
le tueur a évité de se montrer à la
caméra c'est peut-être qu'il connaissait
les lieux et qu'il pourrait s'agir d'un
proche de Hugues mais alors qui
[Musique]
les enquêteurs vont vite s'apercevoir
qu'en réalité il y a des personnes qui
pouvaient en vouloir à la victime car
Hugues faisait des jaloux étant donné
qu'il avait énormément de relations
féminines on dit bon il est peut-être
tombé sur un mari jalon ça ne le gênait
pas que ce soit la petite amie ou la
femme de quelqu'un donc
[Musique]
un homme va attirer l'attention des
enquêteurs
il s'agit de Marco Lacito le manager de
la victime avec lequel il entretenait
d'ailleurs des relations pour le moins
compliqué il y avait une très grande
rivalité entre eux et je me demande s'il
y avait pas des histoires de femmes
entre eux Hugues de la Plaza et une
relation sexuelle ou sentimentale avec
la femme de ce de ce collègue de travail
c'est la thèse qui nous a retenu le plus
longtemps possible et pour cause
interviewée en 2010 lors d'une émission
de télévision américaine consacrée au
meurtre
Marco Lacito n'est pas très tendre avec
son ex-cola
jouer le petit français
on peut le dire
Marc Lacito est-il pour autant impliqué
dans la mort de Hugues de la Plaza les
policiers français ne trouveront aucun
élément à charge contre lui
tout ça n'est qu'une rumeur et
vérification faite ça semble
complètement impossible j'ai parlé de
savoir plusieurs fois et je sais quand
quelqu'un
si ce n'est pas Marco la sitôt alors qui
a tué le jeune Français
un début de réponse ne se fait pas
attendre car les derniers résultats
d'analyse des laboratoires français
viennent justement de tomber sur le
bureau des enquêteurs
la découverte
[Musique]
et on ne sait pas qui
faut de temps et faute de moyens on ne
saura jamais à qui appartient cet ADN et
sans preuve tangible ni piste sérieuse
pour nommer un suspect crédible l'équipe
française doit se résoudre à rentrer en
France
quand ils sont reparti moi moi j'ai
suivi j'ai d'ailleurs rencontré les
policiers à Paris aussi
[Musique]
qui nous ont dit bon off un peu
officiellement mais off une maison dit
que on peut hésiter persuadé que c'était
un assassinat
qui comprenait pas comment le FF pilier
travaillait
et que malheureusement ils avaient pas
de preuves tangibles
non pas de piste
pourtant pas question de baisser les
bras voilà maintenant plus d'un non CUG
le fils de François est mort et la
vérité n'a toujours pas été établie le
père éploré va donc tenter le tout pour
après le départ des enquêteurs français
François de la Plaza décide de se battre
avec les armes américaines
il offre une récompense 100000 dollars
soit près de 90 000 euros à qui
fournirait des informations sur cette
affaire
le père de la victime placard des
affiches dont tous San Francisco
qui permettrait de trouver les coupables
[Musique]
et je pense que c'était la bonne chose à
faire
d'ailleurs cette récompense va faire
éclore une nouvelle hypothèse et
peut-être un nouveau suspect
la dernière hypothèse c'est un crime de
l'intérieur c'est à dire un crime commis
par un voisin qui n'a ni à rentrer ni à
sortir de l'immeuble qui serait
séduisant comme hypothèse puisque la
vidéo n'a filmé personne d'autre que
Hugues de la Plaza rentrant chez lui
pour mieux comprendre cette piste il
suffit de regarder la résidence où
vivait de la Plaza
au rez-de-chaussée à gauche de
l'appartement de Hugues il y a
titanjalibuchane et son compagnon
au premier étage à droite qui un jeune
homme célibataire souvenez-vous celui
qui a découvert les tâches de sang sur
le péron
enfin l'appartement situé au premier
étage à gauche est habité par un
électricien Craig qui vit avec son
compagnon et ses Craig qui va justement
attirer les suspicions car l'appel à
témoin va porter ses fruits
c'est le détective privé payé par le
père de la victime qui a reçu un étrange
appel
ienne
le soir
ce mystérieux informateur dit-il vrai
vous souhaitent-ils seulement toucher la
prime en dénonçant gratuitement Craig le
voisin
Murphy le détective privé décide
d'enquêter sur les deux hommes du
premier étage
ils étaient un peu fou il vivait dans
l'appartement depuis très longtemps
probablement depuis les années 70
une fois j'étais au travail et mon mari
m'appelle de la maison pour me dire
est-ce que je dois appeler la police
parce que l'un des deux hommes au-dessus
est en train de crier l'autre pleure et
l'insuline va tuer l'autre
règle le voisin instable aurait-il pu
attaquer Hugues
selon le détective ce serait possible
et ce n'est pas tout le détective privé
a découvert que Craig l'électricien ne
quitte jamais un objet très particulier
il y a toujours sur lui un petit couteau
ce couteau pourrait-il être l'arme du
crime
Craig est-il un suspect potentiel
pour François de la Plaza le père de la
victime
cela ne colle pas
c'est un gros cutter d'électricien pour
dénuyer les fils la langue quoi fait 4
cm de largeur donc c'est incompatible
avec les blessures qui avaient reçu
[Musique]
l'ADN de tous les intervenants parce que
et on n'a pas le droit ils ne peuvent
relever la bien des personnes que si les
personnes sont d'accord et s'il y a des
motifs sérieux de de suspicion sur ces
personnes
alors qui a tué Hugues de la Plaza un
mari jaloux un dealer un voisin drogué
au fil des années certains proches de la
victime ont arrêté de mener l'enquête la
douleur et la lassitude ont eu raison de
leur désir de justice
un moment donné ça m'a tellement énervé
que j'ai décidé d'arrêter le combat quoi
je pense que l'affaire restera
de leur côté en Bretagne François et
Mireille de la Plaza conserve une
détermination intacte on y va comme ça
je sais pas c'est comme quand on marche
dans la forêt on sait pas où on va tout
droit on se demande pas s'il y a un arme
la porte quoi on cherche et tout
comment s'était passé qui avait fait ça
voilà
[Musique]
entre 100 Francisco et la France chaque
année pour récupérer les informations et
chaque année la police américaine refuse
de coopérer avec eux
ne vous en faites pas
vrai
mais François de la Plaza s'accroche il
lui reste un espoir
consiste à explorer
François de la Plaza n'a plus qu'une
corde à son arc sa dernière cartouche
c'est l'ADN retrouver sur la montre de
son fils
[Musique]
qui pourrait être indication
intéressante mais là encore François de
la Plaza se retrouve seul
François essaye par ses propres moyens
de récupérer l'ADN de d'amis de voisins
de tout ça et essaye de faire les
analyses lui-même
il continuera d'enquêter
la récompense de 100000 dollars qui
permettra d'arrêter le meurtrier de
Hugues de la Plaza tient toujours
le prix de la vérité
le prix de la justice